When you hear the phrase the
American Dream, what immediately
pops into your mind?
Like right now?
Is it that sprawling mansion?
You know, the perfect lawn?
Maybe a private jet waiting on
the tarmac, or maybe a garage
full of fancy cars you see
online.
Get the images, we get
bombarded.
With exactly, or is it
something, I don't know,
simpler, like maybe just a
decent home, a steady job, your
family's comfortable, right.
Because what we think the dream
is today versus what it what it
actually was for a long time.
Well, they might be two really
profoundly different things.
Oh.
Absolutely.
It's true.
The whole concept, the idea of
the American Dream, it's gone
through this like radical
transformation, almost a
complete rewrite, you could say,
over the last few decades.
Why rewrite?
Yeah.
And what's really fascinating,
may be a little heartbreaking
actually, is how that change has
left so many people feeling like
they're chasing, I don't know, a
ghost, a success that's always
just just out of reach, you
know, like, you can't quite
grasp it exactly.
No matter how hard they work, it
feels like the goal posters keep
shifting further and further
away.
And the path, the way to
actually get there, feels like
it's just vanished.
That's precisely it, that
feeling, and that's what we're
doing today.
We're taking a deep dive into
how this whole idea of wealth,
of success in America has
shifted so profoundly.
We're going to explore why that
dream, the one that used to
feel, you know, achievable now
feels so incredibly out of reach
for so many.
And crucially, how modern
culture, maybe especially social
media, that constant presence,
how that feeds into this
feeling, this kind of pervasive
inadequacy and frankly,
disillusionment.
So our mission today really is
to unpack that journey, the
whole evolution of the American
Dream.
We'll trace it from its
beginnings, which were pretty
modest, actually very tangible,
based on stability, achievable
goals, traced all the way to
where we are now.
Or it often feels like this
unattainable, super glamorous
fantasy.
We'll look at the history, the
context, dissect the huge
economic shifts that really
change the game, and, yeah,
examine the undeniable, really
powerful influence of social
media in reshaping what we all
think we should be aiming for.
And we're doing this by drawing
insights from a really
interesting source titled The
Dream Without a Ladder,
America's Illusions of Wealth
and Success.
The dream without a ladder.
It's a great title.
Really hits the nail on the
head, doesn't it?
It really does, and it brings us
straight to a question for you
listening right now.
Have you ever felt like that?
Like that ladder to success, the
one you see everywhere in pop
culture?
It just isn't really there
anymore.
Like you can clearly see the
goal, you know, the fancy
lifestyle, the easy success, but
the actual steps, the runs you
need to climb to get there.
They just sort of vanished,
disappeared from under your
feet.
It's a very common feeling.
It is, and as we're going to
unpack, there's some very solid
reasons why so many people feel
that way.
Yeah, indeed.
What the source material really
shows is that the very the very
nature of the dream itself has
fundamentally changed.
It's not just that the climb got
harder, it's like the perception
now is that there isn't even a
climbable structure there at all
for most people.
OK, let's dig into that then.
Yeah, because to really get a
handle on where we are now, we
absolutely have to go back.
We need to understand what the
American Dream used to look
like, right?
Because it was dramatically
different from the stuff we see
flashed across her screens
constantly.
The core idea?
Historically, it was all about
modesty and, critically,
attainability.
Attainability, that's the
keyword, yeah.
It wasn't about, you know, crazy
access or showing off wealth.
It was about something much more
basic, stability, just having a
secure foundation to build your
life on.
Exactly.
And when you look at how people
describe the traditional dream,
the components were incredibly
grounded, almost almost boring
by today's standards.
You might.
We're talking about phrases that
promise just basic but, you
know, dignified comfort, like a
chicken in every pot.
Right, the classic.
Or a car in every driveway.
Think about that classic
picture.
A2 bedroom ranch house bought on
one salary.
The idea that one person working
could comfortably support a
family.
Yeah, that feels almost mythical
now.
Doesn't it?
And the expectation was simply
that your kids would do a little
better than their parents.
Not massively better, just a bit
better.
This wasn't some, you know, far
fetched, impossible ideal.
It was the common, widely
accepted, accessible ambition
for most people.
And that's the absolute key,
isn't it?
It wasn't about private jets or
mansions in the Hamptons, or,
you know, jetting off to Bali
every other month.
It was about building a solid,
stable foundation, owning a
small piece of America, maybe
having the security of knowing
your kids had a clear shot at a
slightly better life than yours.
And that modesty, that's what
gave it his strength, really.
Exactly.
It was believable, tangible.
And that believability, that
sense of possibility, that's
what fueled generations.
It gave people a clear target,
something to aim for and a
feeling of shared progress.
It was described, as you said,
like a ladder.
You could actually climb rung by
rung.
Yeah.
The steps were clear.
They were concrete, tangible,
like.
What?
What were those runks?
Steady work, right?
Maybe working for the same
company for decades, Diligently
paying off your mortgage over
say 30 years until the house was
truly yours, free and clear.
A huge milestone.
Huge.
It meant your kids having a
decent chance to go to, say, a
state school, get a good
education and graduate without
being buried under a mountain of
crippling debt.
There was a visible path, an
actionable path, a widely
understood road map to achieving
that basic comfort and security.
And this just stands in such
stark contrast to the modern
idea of wealth, which often
feels so elusive.
You know, back then, the steps
were right there.
You could see them, work towards
them.
You saw your neighbors doing it
today.
For so many people, it feels
like those steps are either
hidden or they just don't exist
for the average person anymore.
You're just kind of adrift
looking at these images with no
clear way to get there.
And connecting this back, that
phrase, a chicken in every pot,
it has this really fascinating
history that perfectly
illustrates this point about
modesty and, crucially,
plausibility.
Oh yeah, where did it actually
come?
From Well, what's really
interesting is it doesn't even
originate in America.
No kidding.
Nope, it actually goes way back
to 16th century France.
Wow, it's a attributed to King
Henry the Fourth.
He apparently wished that every
single peasant in his Kingdom
could have a chicken polo pot in
their pot every Sunday.
Every Sunday, not every day.
Exactly.
It wasn't about luxury feasts.
For that time, it was actually a
pretty revolutionary idea.
It was about basic dignity,
about sustenance, about a
modest, attainable level of
comfort for everyone.
It spoke to that fundamental
need for security not showing
off.
OK, so how did it jump across
the pond and become such an
American thing?
Well.
Centuries later, it resurfaced
right here in the US in 1928,
smack in the middle of the
Roaring 20s.
You know that era, big economic
boom, lots of optimism.
Republican businessmen ran this
big ad in the New York World,
and they were basically
bragging, boasting about
Republican prosperity.
And their claim, bold as brass,
was that this prosperity has had
put the proverbial chicken in
every pot, and a car in every
backyard to boot.
Wow.
That's quite a claim, linking
policy directly to, well, dinner
and driveways.
Exactly.
It was a powerful image,
suggesting that economic success
would directly translate into a
better, more comfortable life
for everybody.
But there's some political irony
there, right?
It didn't quite play out
smoothly.
Oh, not at all.
The Democrats, like Al Smith,
jumped all over it.
They totally mocked the idea.
Oh.
So.
Well, they pointed out the huge
disconnect for most working
people back then.
Smith famously asked how a guy
making just $17.50 a week, which
was pretty standard for many
workers, could possibly expect
chicken dinners in a car.
Yeah, seems unlikely.
Right.
Let alone the silk socks some
other people were apparently
enjoying.
So it immediately became the
symbol of a dream that even in
the boom times was still out of
reach for a lot of folks.
It kind of exposed the
inequality bubbling just beneath
the surface.
And didn't it get tied to Hoover
somehow, even though he didn't
actually say it?
Yeah, that's the strange part.
Through this weird twist of
political fate and just public
perception, it got stuck to
Herbert Hoover.
It became the symbol of the
era's optimism, even though he
never personally promised it.
OK.
And then, of course, the cruel
irony hit during the Great
Depression.
That slogan, a chicken in every
pot, which was meant to be
hopeful.
It turned incredibly bitter.
Yeah, I could imagine.
It became this awful reminder of
a promise completely shattered.
You had people living in
Hoovervilles, these shanty
towns, and they turn their empty
pockets inside out and call them
Hoover flags, stark symbols of
just how bad things were, how
wide the gap was between that
promised prosperity and the
brutal reality.
God, that's grim.
But the phrase itself still
stuck around.
Incredibly resilient.
Even as late as 1960 you had JFK
joking about it on the campaign
trail.
He'd tell crowds Hoover hadn't
promised one chicken, but 2
chickens in every pot.
OK, the fact that he could still
joke about it even decades later
just shows how deeply that image
of attainable comfort, of basic
prosperity, was baked into the
American psyche.
It's meaning shifted, sure, from
a King's wish to a political
promise to a symbol of broken
dreams.
But the core idea that
fundamental well-being stayed
powerful.
So the real power of the phrase
tracing it all the way back
wasn't about luxury.
Not at all.
It was about plausibility.
That's the essence of it.
Americans, by and large, weren't
dreaming of yachts or estates.
They wanted the basics.
The chicken, the car, a roof
overhead.
It was modest, yes, but it felt
reachable.
It spoke to the dignity of
everyday life.
The idea that hard work could
lead to a stable existence, it
felt within grasp.
And that specific idea, that
plausibility, that's precisely
where the story takes a dramatic
turn, isn't it?
This whole era of modest,
achievable dreams, that
foundation of plausibility we've
just mapped out, well, it didn't
last.
It started crack.
Then it started to crumble.
And that ladder, the one people
had climbed for generations, run
by rung, it began to fall apart.
Yeah, that's right.
That critical sense of
plausibility, that shared belief
in a dream you could actually
reach it, really started to
erode in the late 20th century.
When exactly?
Specifically, it seems to be
after that post World War 2
boom.
You know, the supposed golden
age, suburban growth,
manufacturing jobs after that
period.
That's when, as our source puts
it so well, something broke the
foundation of that old dream,
the one that relied on a
predictable economy, accessible
opportunities.
It just started to crack under
all these new pressures,
economic pressures, global
shifts.
And we can point to some really
specific things that caused this
collapse, right?
Oh definitely 1st and maybe the
biggest one was wage stagnation.
OK, what does that mean exactly?
It means that for decades,
really starting around the
1970s, wages for most American
workers just stopped keeping up.
They stopped keeping pace with
the rising cost of living and,
critically, they stopped keeping
pace with how much more
productive workers were
becoming.
As if people were producing more
but not getting paid
proportionally more.
Exactly.
There's that showing.
Like between the early 70s and
maybe 2018, productivity shot up
something like 77%.
Huge increase.
But average hourly wages for
regular workers, after you
adjust for inflation, they only
went up about 12%.
Wow.
That's a massive gap.
It's a huge disconnect.
And that one salary dream we
talked about where one income
could support a family, buy a
house, that became harder and
harder.
And then for many, it's
impossible.
It meant the rungs on that
ladder weren't just getting
further apart.
Some were basically
disappearing.
Yeah.
At the same time wages were
stagnating costs for basic stuff
or.
Skyrocketing, absolutely
unprecedented increases and
things that used to be
fundamental necessities.
Housing is the big one, right?
Especially in cities and
suburbs.
Prices just ballooned out of
reach for millions.
What used to be a reasonable
investment became the
speculative thing driven by big
money, not just people needing a
place to live.
And healthcare, education, same
story.
Healthcare costs went through
the roof.
Even if you had insurance
through work, the deductibles,
the co-pays, the prescription
costs, it became this huge
source of financial stress for
families And education.
College costs, student loans,
they escalated way faster than
inflation.
So higher Ed went from being
this ladder up to becoming this
crushing weight, leaving
graduates with tons of debt
before they even started.
These weren't luxuries, these
were basics that suddenly became
luxury items.
Pulling the dream further away.
Further and further away.
And then came 2008, the
financial crisis.
That wasn't just a dip, was it?
Oh God no.
That was a full blown
catastrophe.
It was the seismic event that
just brutally exposed how
fragile this whole redefined
dream had become.
The housing market crashed
spectacularly.
Because of reckless lending,
most subprime mortgages, complex
financial products, nobody
really understood.
It all just unraveled and it was
devastating.
Millions of people who genuinely
believed they were climbing that
ladder, you know, doing the
right thing by buying a home.
They suddenly saw that ladder
just collapsed beneath them
instantly.
Imagine the shock, the
psychological blow, putting
everything into your home and
then watching its value just
evaporate.
Or worse, owing more than it was
worth.
Exactly.
That's the underwater mortgage.
Their equity, years of savings
and hard work gone overnight.
Mortgages underwater meant they
couldn't sell without huge
losses.
Many lost their homes entirely
through foreclosure.
So the family home, once the
symbol of stability.
Turned into a financial
trapdoor, sucking people into
debt and uncertainty.
It wasn't just a financial
crisis.
It felt like a betrayal.
A crisis of trust in the whole
system, in the promise of the
dream itself.
And the impact of that, the
psychological impact, it must
have been huge, a loss of faith.
Deep, pervasive.
You still feel the echoes today.
People didn't just find the
ladder hard to climb anymore.
They genuinely started to wonder
if the ladder was even real or
if it had been pulled up
completely.
The trust in the system, in that
predictable path.
Work hard, buy a home, get
ahead.
It was shattered for a lot of
people and it created this deep
void, disillusionment,
resentment.
People felt abandoned, adrift.
And Major abhors a vacuum,
right?
Yeah.
So that void, that empty space
left by the crumbling
traditional dream, something
filled.
It almost immediately,
seamlessly, you could say
something new stepped in,
something powerful and something
profoundly different and
arguably deeply problematic,
which is social media.
Right.
Yeah, This is where it gets
really genuinely insidious.
I think because social media
didn't just, like, offer an
alternative view, it completely
changed the entire game of
aspiration itself.
How so?
Well, think about it.
Old TV sitcoms might show, you
know, relatable families.
Comfortable homes, maybe, but
not wildly extravagant, sensible
cars.
Right, the Cunninghams or the
Cleavers?
Exactly.
But now platforms like
Instagram, TikTok, YouTube, they
deliver this endless, relentless
feed of curated excess.
It's constant, it's visually
stunning, hyper edited, it looks
like effortless success, and
it's hitting you 24/7 right
there on your phone.
Yeah, every scroll is a
potential comparison trap.
Totally.
And it's always this very
specific, highly aspirational
image designed to make you feel,
well, envious or inadequate.
What kind of images are you
talking?
About oh, you know the ones.
The penthouse apartment in New
York with the insane view.
The casual vacation in Bali?
Looks like they just woke up
there.
The brand new luxury SUV parked
perfectly in the driveway.
The shopping halls.
Huge shopping hall designer bags
laid out just so, or the entire
lifestyle brand built around
looking effortlessly rich,
traveling constantly, eating
amazing food.
It's this nonstop glittering
display.
It feels like it's everywhere
online but nowhere near your
actual life.
And the really tricky part, the
most insidious part of this new
dream, this new standard, is how
accessible it pretends to be.
Yes, that's the key.
Explain that.
The lie, the core deception, is
that it's not presented like
some Hollywood fantasy.
You know, something only movie
stars achieved.
No, no, it's cleverly packaged
as normal people just like you
who figured it out, who made it.
Right, the hustle culture
narrative sometimes.
Exactly.
You see these influencers and
they work really hard to seem
accessible.
They share their morning
routines.
They give you behind the scenes
glimpses.
They talk about their journey
from, you know, humble
beginnings, all while showcasing
a lifestyle that is, if you just
do the math, fundamentally
unattainable for the vast
majority of the people watching
them.
It's a performance, a carefully
constructed illusion.
And certain figures become
almost like templates for this,
don't they?
Absolutely.
Think about figures like the
Kardashians.
They aren't just celebrities
anymore.
Admired from afar, they've
become the actual template for
what success is supposed to look
like now.
Their lives, their possessions,
the apparent ease, the constant
stream of perfectly curated
moments that's held up
implicitly or explicitly as the
gold standard.
It's a total redefinition of
making it the goal posts have
moved from stability and
security to just relentless,
visible performative luxury in
the.
Psychological hit on, you know,
you, the listener on all of us
seeing this constantly.
It's huge.
It's damaging, yeah.
Because if you don't measure up,
and how could you to this highly
curated, often unreal,
fundamentally unattainable
standard, it feels like personal
failure.
Right, like you're doing
something wrong.
Exactly.
It breeds this intense pressure,
this gnawing sense of
inadequacy.
You feel like you're falling
short, even if by any
traditional healthy measure
you're actually doing OK or even
great.
It's just this constant,
exhausting comparison against
somebody else's highlight reel.
OK, so on one side we have this
nonstop fantasy feat.
But what about the reality?
What about actual wealth in
America?
The kind that doesn't make it
onto Instagram?
Ah yeah, that's where the
contrast becomes incredibly
stark.
It really highlights the huge
gap between perception and
reality, a gap that I think too
few people really understand or
even think about.
Because the reality is often,
well, kind of boring.
Exactly the boring reality of
most millionaires that's never
going viral.
Our source uses this great
example.
Arlington, VA.
OK, what's special about
Arlington?
Apparently it's just packed with
millionaires and not the kind
you see on TV.
These are like government
workers, teachers, civil
servants.
Really.
Yeah.
People who put in their 30
years, maybe maxed out their
retirement plans religiously
every single year.
Maybe they bought their houses
way back in the 80s or 90s when
prices were totally different.
Right when it was actually
affordable.
Exactly.
And then they just let compound
interest in real estate
appreciation do the quiet,
steady, unspectacular work of
building wealth over decades.
So on paper, they're
millionaires.
They have the net worth.
Definitely often millions, but
their daily lives, you'd never
know it just by looking at them.
What do you mean?
They're driving, you know, a
reliable 10 year old Camry or a
Honda, not a Ferrari.
They're cooking dinner at home
most nights, probably watching
their grocery budget.
They're worrying about their
kids student loans, just like
lots of other middle class
families.
Their lifestyle doesn't scream
rich in that social media way.
It screams responsible,
disciplined, patient.
There's no flash, no showing
off, just quiet financial
security built over time.
And that is precisely why that
story never makes it onto TikTok
or your Instagram feed.
Bingo.
It's not glamorous, it's not
click bait, it doesn't offer
some magic hack or get rich
quick secret.
No overnight success.
None.
It's the story of consistent
effort, careful budgeting,
sensible long term investing,
decades of it, and honestly, who
wants to watch a video about
someone driving an old car and
packing a lunch when the next
video is a private jet taking
off for some exotic island?
Yeah, it doesn't compete
visually.
Not at all.
The very nature of how this kind
of wealth is built slowly,
quietly, is the opposite of the
instant gratification and
visible performance that social
media thrives on.
And this disconnect, this
reality gap, it leads to another
really important point, doesn't
it, about how we've kind of
quietly redefined what
millionaire even means.
Yes.
We've inflated the goal posts
almost without noticing.
It's not really just about
having $1,000,000 anymore, is
it?
Culturally, anyway.
The constant exposure to extreme
wealth, the sheer concentration
of money at the very, very top,
the media portrayals, it's all
subtly shifted the scale.
First maybe it was, oh, a
million isn't really rich.
Then maybe the benchmark crept
up to $10 million, and now
culturally, the idea of being
really rich is maybe closer to
$100 million for some people.
Wow, 100 million.
There's this almost darkly funny
anecdote in the Source about
Renaissance Weekend.
You know, that exclusive
gathering for wealthy
influential types?
Apparently the insiders there
used to joke that you weren't
really rich until you hit $10
million.
But recently, that inside joke,
that informal benchmark, has
apparently jumped all the way to
$100 million.
Think about it.
Just having $1,000,000, which
for most people on Earth is
still a life altering amount of
money, it's become culturally
diminished, almost insignificant
in this inflated narrative of
what rich means.
The term millionaire itself has
almost been devalued by this
constant exposure to hyperwell.
This constant upward
redefinition of success
inflating what millionaire means
it has a real consequence,
doesn't.
It a silent but really corrosive
effect, because while we're all
maybe chasing this ever higher,
seemingly impossible gold, the
$10 million, the $100 million
fantasy, the actual ladder, the
one for middle class stability,
the one built on modesty,
saving, steady progress, That
ladder is, as the source says,
quietly rotting.
This cultural inflation makes
real, achievable wealth, the
kind that actually provides
security and freedom from
stress.
Seems small, insignificant,
maybe even like failure.
It actively discourages the very
behaviors saving, investing
modestly, living below your
means that actually lead to
sustainable financial health.
Because why bother saving for a
million if the culture tells you
that's basically nothing?
It's a dangerous game, and this
redefinition, this fantasy
pushed by social media, it sets
up another really common, really
problematic lie, doesn't it?
Yes, another trap.
We get this constant whisper
from consumer culture, from ads,
maybe even from, you know, well
meaning online advice.
What's the whisper?
That the little luxuries don't
matter, that your small daily
splurges, they don't really
impact your overall financial
health in the grand scheme of
things.
Right, the latte factor debate,
kind of.
Exactly.
It's the soothing idea, this
reassurance.
Go ahead, get the fancy coffee
every day.
Order take out for every meal,
Subscribe to everything the
narrative suggests.
These little things won't
actually derail you, because the
real problem is the system.
OK, the false justification is
basically you could afford a
house, you could build wealth
even while spending like crazy
on daily stuff, if only the
system wasn't stacked against
you with high housing costs,
stagnant wages, all that.
It's a comforting thought.
I guess it's not my fault.
It's comforting, but it's also a
really dangerous delusion.
OK, but let's be fair, the
system is stacked against a lot
of people, right?
Oh absolutely.
Yes, let's be very clear about
that.
Housing costs are insane in many
places.
Wages have stagnated for decades
for average folks.
The playing field is definitely
not level.
Those systemic issues are
absolutely real and they need
fixing.
But, and this is the crucial
point for you, the listener to
really get because it combines
acknowledging the system and
personal agency, Your burn rate
matters too.
Your burn rate, meaning how much
you spend day-to-day.
Exactly.
Your daily spending habits, your
lifestyle choices, the
cumulative impact of all those
seemingly small purchases.
They absolutely, undeniably
affect your ability to save, to
invest, to build wealth, to
climb whatever ladder might
still exist.
So you can't just ignore it.
Ignoring your burn rate while
blaming the system is like, I
don't know, I'm trying to bail
out a leaky boat with a sieve
while also leaving the faucet
running full blast.
It just doesn't work.
This brings us back to that
Millionaire Next Door idea,
doesn't it?
That book from years ago.
It does.
That concept popularized by
Stanley and Danko.
It feels more relevant now than
ever, maybe because the
practical steps those folks
take, the ones who quietly build
real wealth, they're incredibly
consistent and profoundly
unspectacular.
Like what?
Remind us.
They save diligently, often
automatically.
They prioritize future security
over buying the next cool thing
right now.
They cook at home way more often
than they eat out or get
delivery, saving thousands a
year.
They drive older, reliable cars
paid off, avoiding that constant
cycle of car payments and
depreciation.
Right, they're not leasing a new
BMW every three years.
Exactly.
And maybe most importantly, they
invest steadily over the long
haul.
Sensible investments,
diversification, Letting
compound interest do its quiet
magic over decades.
And the result of all that
discipline, that seemingly
boring stuff?
The result is they
systematically build equity.
They build retirement savings.
It's slow, yes, it's steady.
It's definitely not glamorous.
It's not going to make you
famous online.
But it works consistently
predictably.
And contrast that with.
Contrast that with a family that
spends pretty much everything
they earn on lifestyle, always
upgrading the phone, the car,
the house, constantly consuming,
chasing the next visible luxury.
That family, even if they have a
great income, they might never
build the ladder at all.
Because there's nothing
leftover.
Exactly.
They're traps living paycheck to
paycheck, even if it's a big
paycheck because they're burn
rate eats up everything.
There's no surplus to save, no
capital to invest.
And this, you're saying, is the
unpopular truth.
Sadly, yes.
This story, the millionaire next
door story of slow, disciplined
wealth building, it's often the
one no one wants to hear.
Why not?
Because it sounds, well, boring.
And maybe a little judgmental
compared to the sexy fantasy of
striking it rich overnight.
The crypto windfall.
The instant influencer fame.
Yeah, that sounds more exciting.
It does, but the boring path
demands patience.
It demands sacrifice, delaying
gratification, things our
instant culture doesn't value
much anymore.
It means actually looking at
your own spending, which can be
uncomfortable.
And it offers no quick fixes,
just steady, deliberate progress
over a long time.
OK, so if we pull all these
threads together now, where does
it leave us?
It feels like we're caught
between these two powerful,
conflicting ideas, these
illusions.
That's exactly right.
We're trapped as a society, as
individuals, between two huge
illusions, 2 big lies that are
constantly bombarding us, and
the really tragic outcome is
that both of them fundamentally
warp our imagination.
They twist our understanding of
what success even is, and they
lead us down paths that
ultimately go nowhere.
OK, so recap the two illusions
for us.
The first illusion.
That's the fantasy of the
glamorous overnight millionaire.
Right, Instagram life.
Exactly.
The crypto kings, the influencer
lifestyles, the Kardashian model
of success.
It's this constant aspirational
feed, pushed relentlessly by
social media, promising a fast,
effortless path to huge wealth
and visible luxury.
It sets this impossible
benchmark for making it.
Got it.
And the second illusion.
That's the consumer culture
whisper that constant nudge,
telling you it's fine, maybe
even smart, to spend recklessly
on the little luxuries that you
can still get ahead, still
achieve wealth, if only the
system wasn't rigged against
you.
Yeah, the one that subtly lets
you off the hook for your
spending.
Precisely.
It absolves personal
responsibility by blaming
everything on the system.
And while the system has
problems, ignoring your own
choices is dangerous.
And both of these are lies.
Fundamentally, they aren't just
misleading, they're deeply
damaging falsehoods.
Both of them warp the
imagination.
They distort what we aspire to.
They divert our attention from
what the real American Dream
actually was, and maybe what it
still needs to be if people are
going to genuinely find
stability and security.
They create this huge
unbridgeable gap between what we
expect and what's real.
Because the real American dream,
going back to the beginning, if
we strip away the modern hype,
the Instagram filters, the
consumerism, it was always about
something very different.
Totally different.
It was modest, it was slow, it
was built on tangible effort,
hard work, and crucially, it was
genuinely achievable for a lot
of people.
A broad cross section.
And that was its power.
That was its power, its
strength.
Why it resonated for so long
came directly from that
attainability, from the
widespread, deeply held belief
that if you worked hard, played
by the rules, lived within your
means, you could actually get
there.
So the tragedy, then, isn't
simply that the American Dream
is dead.
That's too simple, right?
That's the common way to put it,
but it misses the nuance.
The profound insight here, the
one our source really hammers
home, is that the dream wasn't
just killed off, it was
replaced.
Replaced by what?
Replaced by a dream with no
staircase.
Wow.
OK, unpack that.
No staircase.
The traditional steps, the
tangible rungs, the affordable
home, the steady job that paid
enough, the manageable education
costs, the clear path to
building equity.
Over time, those were gradually
dismantled, or they became
inaccessible.
For too many people, it left
this huge gap, this chasm
between where people were and
where the dream supposedly was.
The destination might still be
visible, maybe even amplified,
but the path just disappeared.
Can you compare the two dreams
directly?
The old versus the new.
Yeah, think about it starkly.
The old dream.
A chicken in the pot.
A car in the driveway.
Modest.
Tangible.
Never glamorous, right?
Not designed to make your
neighbors jealous, But they were
real.
They felt like something you
could earn through effort,
discipline, patience.
There's a visible path.
A ladder was there, even if it
was hard to climb sometimes.
And the new dream.
The penthouse in Malibu, the
private jet to Tulum, the closet
overflowing with designer stuff.
These aren't just hard to get.
For most people, they are simply
illusions.
But they're presented as real.
Exactly.
Presented as normal, even.
But they're fundamentally
unattainable fantasies for the
vast majority.
And worse than just being
illusions, the source argues,
they're dead ends.
Dead ends.
Why?
Because they offer no path
between the ground and the sky.
There's no ladder, there are no
tangible steps, there's no clear
actionable strategy that
connects your reality today to
that glamorous image.
It's a destination with no Rd.
leading to it.
And that leads to the final,
really powerful conclusion.
Yeah, without a ladder, a dream
is just a taunt.
A taunt It's.
Cruel, isn't it?
It's this constant glittering
reminder of what you don't have,
like what it feels like you
can't achieve no matter how hard
you work by the old rules.
Yeah, the societal impact is
massive.
You have immigrants coming here
expecting the Kardashian life
because that's the image of
America they see.
And facing crushing reality.
Crushing disappointment.
You have native born folks
feeling like total failures
because they're merely
comfortable.
They have a stable job, a decent
home, a family, but it doesn't
look like the fantasy on the
screen so it feels inadequate.
This huge gap between the screen
and the driveway basically.
This widening, unbridgeable gap.
It leads to widespread
disappointment, chronic anxiety,
deep feelings of inadequacy, a
constant sense that you're
falling behind no matter what.
It's a crisis of expectation,
really, fueled by this totally
flawed, deliberately inflated
idea of success that sets almost
everyone up to feel like they're
failing.
It erodes trust, breeds
resentment and undermines that
collective hope that used to be
part of the story.
And that really brings us to the
end of our deep dive today.
Looking at the dream without a
ladder, the big take away, the
central revelation is really
understanding this profound,
often painful shift from a
tangible ladder real
attainability to this elusive
screen based fantasy of wealth
that offers no real way forward.
Yeah, and it's a shift that's
had very real, very significant
consequences for all of us.
It affects how we define
success, how we define failure,
and how we see our own place in
the world.
So as we wrap up, we really want
to invite you, the listener, to
think about this.
How do you define success in
this new landscape that
sometimes confusing reality?
What parts of that old dream,
the modesty, the stability, the
tangible steps, maybe the
dignity of just doing good work,
what parts of that still
resonate deeply with you?
And based on what we've talked
about, are there deliberate
steps you can take towards
building a dream that's truly
achievable, truly fulfilling for
you?
Maybe one that's grounded more
in your reality and sustainable
choices rather than chasing
those fleeting illusions on a
screen.
Maybe it does mean taking
another look at your own burn
rate, or maybe embracing some of
that quiet, boring discipline of
the millionaire next door.
Finding your own ladder perhaps?
And here's a final thought to
leave you with Given that our
culture has so dramatically
shifted the goal posts, moving
the definition of success away
from modesty and stability
towards glamorous access,
consider this how might society
be implicitly redefining failure
as a result?
That's a heavy question.
It is if just being comfortably
stable is no longer seen as
enough.
What does that mean for your
personal well-being?
Your mental health, your sense
of self worth.
And what are the hidden costs,
the collective costs of that
redefinition on our shared
aspirations, on our ability to
build something real and lasting
instead of just chasing a
fantasy?
Yeah.
Something definitely worth
pondering as you navigate your
own path in this this very
transformed world.